c'est le moment où la séance démarre ce
matin
tatiana a décidé de s'entraîner à la
fraîche comme elle dit la pause avant
qu'il fasse trop chaud je place mes prix
lâcheront ma barre correctement il est 8
heures et au fond de la ravine saint leu
on entend que les oiseaux qui chantent
le câble est placé à quatre mètres 50
sur une longueur de 20 mètres
la perche elle fait 4 mètres de long et
pèse 14 août ils balançaient est
toujours placé à ce milieu et au niveau
du nombril et l'équilibré se trouve un
tueur le bougeant de gauche à droite
comme ça donc ça c'est un peu là le
premier niveau que tu regarde devant toi
après tu peux commencer à travailler
avec les doubles attention c'est à dire
pouvoir regarder sur le côté pour
pouvoir regarder de l'autre côté
regarder en l'air
regardez en bas être libre au niveau des
yeux
ça c'est vraiment la base du funambule
[Musique]
temps ça a l'air facile c'est que c'est
bien fait ok après il faut aussi savoir
que toutes ces positions là qui sont des
positions de pause avant de réussir à se
poser dessus c'est des semaines et des
semaines de douleurs intenses en général
au début ça fait des bleus et puis la
peau commence à s'écraser
et puis chaque chose commence à prendre
sa place et après c'est bon on est
capable de respirer dedans mais c'est
toujours avoir mal pour ensuite être à
l'aise c'est génial comme discipline
[Rires]
[Musique]
je m'arrêtais la catena ne doit pas trop
se fatiguer car elle a deux spectacles
cet après-midi avant d'aller se reposer
elle jette quand même un coup d'oeil aux
falaises de la ravine saint leu avait
clairement une petite idée en tête
on a une petite idée qui ré de ce rocher
la barre qui traverserait toute la
ravine et qui est greffée sur ce rocher
et cesserait une traversée à 60 mètres
de haut environ sur 200 m de long alors
ça ce serait très intéressant de voir ça
et si oui après une petite sieste
tatiana rejoint le village du festival à
table et le retrouve jean cabaret depuis
près de vingt ans il travaille sur la
programmation du leu tempo est depuis
toujours il rêvait de proposer un vrai
spectacle de funambules
il ya très peu de compagnies qui le font
très peu de femmes voilà et puis métissé
aussi penser qu'on va dire mais dans le
cirque
[Musique]
ces gens métissée et
pour nous c'est important nous à la
réunion d'avoir des parcours comme le
terrain parce que ça montre que le
cirque et pas seulement blanc
totalement blancs européens
c'est vrai que dans les retours c'est
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui viennent me
voir à fin de spectacle du coup
certaines personnes de couleur qui me
disent ah me savais pas que c'était
possible pour nous je me dis déjà se
noue qu'est ce qui veut dire et ensuite
tout est possible pour tout le monde et
la première lors du spectacle approche
c'est là que tatiana nous raconte
comment tout a commencé
elle avait 7 ans gérer une funambule
tracé entre deux immeubles dans mon
quartier et à bout j'ai tout de suite eu
envie de faire exactement la même chose
parce qu'il y avait cette espèce de chez
pas il ya un espèce de sentiment de
liberté de d'épanouissement là dedans
que moi je me sentais pas du tout en
main j'étais quelqu'un de très très
introverti dans mes baskets et
les filles c'est marrant parce que ça va
ça m'a permis de pouvoir me montrer de
pouvoir montrer que j'existe et que je
veux aussi faire des choses grandes me
dire que moi aussi j'avais une place et
que d'aller jusqu'au bout un trou et du
coup aujourd'hui qu'il n'est plus
l'homme est introverti avant chaque
spectacle
c'est le même cérémonial séance de
câlins avant d'affronter le pup 500
spectateurs cet après-midi et première
surprise depuis ce matin le câble a été
démonté toute la structure est
complètement par terre et ça avec l'aide
du public qu'on arrive à tous dressé et
démarrer le spectacle parce que le
funambule pour moi c'est souvent une
image qui est assez solitaire et de la
manière dont j'ai appris la manière dont
je le vis je suis tout seul
et du coup j'avais envie de réussir à
chaque fois à médecins en valeur parce
qu'on a
pour rien que pour monter un funambule
comme celui là on a besoin de deux
techniciens du coup c'était comment
réussir à mettre en valeur tout le monde
pour qu'on puisse se dire que c'est une
traversée qu'on fait tous ensemble sinon
ça ne marche pas
une clique de risques qu à l aide à
l'ancienne trésorerie c'que tu es prête
à risquer ta vie mais je reste n'avait à
chaque instant quand je traverse
s'arrogerait ce que ma vie on imagine
que ça risque sûrement et qu'on brade
tous les tous les dangers qu'on va au
delà de notre limite alors qu'en fait ça
c'est mon métier et je m'entraîne tous
les jours pour ça et c'est devenu
quelque chose de quotidien pour moi je
prends beaucoup plus de risques quand je
prends ma voiture avant de devenir
funambule tatiana a étudié deux ans la
psychologie du coup elle donne de ce qui
est devenu son métier une définition
très haut perché c'est très symbolique
leur train de chercher un équilibre à
des moments donnés on chute
y'a rien qui va qui va puer puis on
essaye de se relever on se rend compte à
quel point
bah rien n'est vraiment important à quel
point on se construit toute une vie avec
des choses hyper stable pour se rassurer
pour se dire que ça dure alors qu en
fait rien de durée que je veux pas du
révolu et que ça fait partie du jeu